senior Trump administration officials
were out in force today touting real
results take a look thank you for
covering economic boom the boom in wages
and labor and growth in jobs in
manufacturing construction which the
poison pens can't touch that's what's
being discussed around kitchen tables
but it wasn't just Trump loyalists even
the New York Times is praising the Trump
economy on Friday it's leading economic
commentator wrote this the headlines for
the August job numbers released this
morning are nothing but good employers
added a robust 201 thousand jobs the
unemployment rate remained at the
rock-bottom level of three point nine
percent and wages grew the fastest they
have in nine years there's no doubt that
this is the best economy in quite a long
time for American workers who by a wide
range of measures can find a job more
easily than they have in a decade
wellmaybe President Trump should tweet
that out and just for once call it the
sometimes gets it right New York Times
Dana this story about the economy is
obviously very good but we're in the
election season now and I've got a
theory that the Republicans to just rely
on the good news isn't enough because
people aren't grateful for what's
happened and the real challenge is to
persuade them that if the Democrats win
or do well all this is at risk they're
the results of the economy are so good
and it's really fun to be in news and
have a chance to actually talk about
people getting jobs and having this
optimism like that's different right
that feels good and it it's interesting
to see that if you read a little deeper
into that New York Times yes there are
basically he's saying there's dark
clouds on the horizon there's not enough
people that are working and there are
concerns about the number the number of
participants but what has happened is
that wages have started to go up because
of that pressure I think that they
cannot the Republicans cannot rest on
the good economy because in a midterm
election as it's been explained to me
sometimes you have to scare your base
into voting so Democrats have done that
and Republicans are certainly doing that
if you look at president Trump's pitch
if Democrats take over all of this goes
away all of these bad things are going
to happen one of the concerns for
President Trump and that's why I think
he is out there on the campaign trail is
that in a presidential election the
economy definitely helps you in a
midterm election the president elects
the Congress and right with likability
being what it is and democratic energy
being what it is that's why the
Republicans have to have a full-court
press I totally agree with that Tesla or
the Democrats it feels to me have you
know they're very little they can say
about this economy because it's the kind
of thing that every Democrat should
welcome in terms of working Americans
well that's why there's not saying
anything about this economy because
obviously it doesn't play well in their
favor where Democrats are focused on is
all emotion not economists were focused
on a motion like Dana was talking about
so where you have Republicans who are
saying you know let's scare people into
you know making sure that all this goes
away you have the Democrat side who is
scaring people into what we see with the
book fear and everything you know it's
gonna continue with this morale that's
taking over the country this big dark
cloud the problem is on the Democrat
side is the Democrats don't get along so
a lot of the sweep under the rug between
the left the all the way out left which
by the way I'm not a part of you know
always have to make that doesn't mean
I'm left and progressive and so my
Twitter want to know do you see
progressives and Democrats as different
and people do they see that as its own
independent party and people's well why
did you work for Sanders if you're not a
socialist well because it needed to get
broke up which you'll talk about you
know about big banks and break we are a
lot lots that were out late a bit
Charlie what do you think is gonna work
this scary well look I'm critical people
typically vote out of anger not
gratitude but there is a lot to be
thankful for without a doubt I mean the
president has improved the economy
tremendously the low taxes are working
the deregulation would I got a kick out
of in this last week is the surprise of
Barack Obama coming back into the
political conversation so if you want to
rev up the Republican base he should
talk every single day from now it's the
midterms and I think you're gonna see
record turnout because it's a it's a
daily reminder Ike oh wait that's why I
came out and voted this kind of
professorial elitist ivory tower
preaching to middle of America you
should be thankful that you know I was
president and now you're reaping the
benefits well no the economy was going
lackluster mediocre at best
the president went through massive
deregulation massive tax cuts was a
cheerleader for America not an apologist
for America now you've seen the GDP rate
higher than the unemployment rate
first time in this century none of that
was achieved under President Obama and
so President Obama it's really funny he
says you need a magic wand to do all
these sorts of things president's done
it but they can't have it both ways
because he said Trump gets elected the
economy's gonna crash okay that didn't
happen therefore under that argument you
have to assume all responsibility for
whatever the economy happens positive or
negative therefore there's no way you
could possibly say he can't take credit
for this economy and it's a hundred
percent because of his optimism the
deregulation the tax cuts the
pro-business environment not to mention
the trade deal that have liberated the
anigh that factor of just the energy and
and the impact on business confidence
when you have a clearly Pro Enterprise
administration really plays but Candace
wanted that every time the president
talks about the economy he quite rightly
points out the great success in terms of
african-american unemployment that's it
that's a point that you you you
reinforce the whole time in terms of
where that community's interests lie but
is it making any headway it absolutely
is making kind of way and we saw that a
couple of weeks ago on the Rasmussen
poll that black support for Donald Trump
has doubled and let me tell you my that
significant we have heard the left
called everything everyone every story
every book racist they've said the word
racist so much it's actually lost its
meaning I don't know what's racist
anymore if my if my server at a
restaurant gives you my coffee I'm like
is this racist you know because this is
how much they are reinforcing the
concept that everything is racist and
they're doing that because they're
scared
bringing back Barack Obama was a sign of
fear make no mistake they threw a Hail
Mary and thought okay we're absolutely
losing especially on the heels of the
showdown with Brett Kavanaugh hearings I
mean that was not good for them and they
knew retrospectively that it was not
good for them Maxine Waters who are
constantly saying to attack people
that's not working well for them
then you have cory booker saying i am
Spartacus and bizarre it was actually
just bizarre right right out theatrical
it's not voting well people are actually
looking at that and going I don't
recognize that because people you have
to give Barack Obama credit for very few
things but here's one of them
he's a very good salesman he was always
calling me always submit he was in
control that is not what the Democrat
Party looks like right now it's
completely splintering a very good point
that you brought up we're seeing
progressives versus you know the
traditional Democrats and this
disruptive sort of aggressive platform
of socialism that's reappearing and
there on
eating Democrats which is bizarre so
it's a very interesting time I think
right now they are under the impression
that there is going to be a red wave and
that's why they're bringing back Barack
Obama well I don't know we've got to
sort of leave it there but I do think
there's no grass at all for complacency
on the Republican side and one thing I
just wanna emphasize what Dana was
saying from that we haven't got time on
for which we discuss it but with that
point you made about the potential
constraints the economy's coming up
against and actually some up to be fair
some of the work that the president's
been doing in Ivanka has been doing on
job training to get people into the
workforce is really important but that
is for another night